this weekend marked world mental health
day and it feels
particularly important this year as we
all face the worrying uncertainty that
coronavirus
brings aleister campbell tony blair's
former director of communications has
spoken out in the past about his own
personal experience and he's written a
book
on surviving depression he joins us now
and
you've been very open about your own
mental health challenges you've spoken
very eloquently about it before just
explain to people who might not been
familiar with
what happened about your own experience
well the book is about my mental health
story and also without my family so
my own psychosis and alcohol problems in
the 80s i had a brother who was
now dead sadly i schizophrenia another
brother who had addiction issues
a cousin who took his own life so i've
tried to kind of tell that story but in
the broader context
of what i think is a growing mental
health crisis which is going to be
exacerbated by some of the things that
you've been talking on
about earlier in the program so i've
really tried to
address my own mental health and i think
i'm now in a better shape than i've ever
been
because i've really gone into it deep
but also then
the second part of the book living
better is about actually trying to find
other ways that other people in
different parts of the world
are looking at depression i call it the
search for cure i'm not sure we'll ever
get a cure
but i do think there are things that we
can do for ourselves and for each other
that can help us to deal with depression
much better and it feels particularly
important
at the moment with the anxiety that we
all feel no matter
what our own experiences are with mental
health with a pandemic i mean it must be
a really really difficult time for so
many people who are
battling with their mental health well
it's interesting
mind and other mental health charities
have been very very clear that although
yes
everybody's struggling to a certain
degree with anxiety
those who have pre-existing mental
health conditions
are the ones who are struggling most and
i think it was really interesting
actually watching your
your program just now um in a sense the
whole story of covet i think
has been that the government has been
constantly trying to catch up
with decisions that it should have been
planning for
and i think maybe the royal college of
psychiatrists have said
that they think mental illness is going
to be the second pandemic
of covid we've seen a huge rise in
people reporting symptoms of depression
the suicide figures are going up and
we've got an economic
catastrophe coming down the track and we
know what happened the last time with
the global financial crisis
there is a direct link to suicide now if
you've got that if you know
that's coming it's the duty of
government to plan for that
and i don't have any sense of the
government planning for this
you hear other world leaders they talk
about mental health
people like jacinda ardern in new
zealand angela merkel cuomo in new york
they've been talking about the mental
health implications from the word go
and we just i don't think we're even the
government's even got this on its radar
it is concerning um there was research
by sky news that showed that over the
last six months there were
actually over 200 000 fewer referrals to
mental health services compared to last
year i was speaking
earlier this week to the chief executive
of saying the mental health charity
saying that
a lot of people are worried about
putting extra strain on the nhs
about coming forward with when they are
really suffering
from mental health issues are you
worried people aren't seeking out the
help they need
well look that is definitely happening
you talk to
and look i've been doing that myself i
mean i had a bit of a
kind of i had a manic spelling locked
down and i also had a very big dick
and you find yourself thinking oh well
i'll just kind of see it through because
and i think that's a natural reaction
because we're all conscious of the fact
that covid
is such a big problem for our health
services but i get the feeling now that
this actually if we're not
careful is going to become an even an
even bigger problem
because what seems to be happening is
yes the cases are going back up
the death rate seems to be fairly being
kept fairly low
fairly stable but i think these mental
health conditions they're storing up and
they're storing up and they're storing
up
and so i think it's it's been
interesting to uh
to listen to people in the health
service saying look if you are
kind of struggling if you are suffering
please do come forward
so i think that we we we've got to
understand that this is going to be the
next wave of this
and i really really worry the
government's not on the case i saw
you mentioned it was world mental health
day yesterday i watched boris johnson's
video about that
i mean there was nothing in it apart
from a few cliches and platitudes and a
few references to william winston
churchill having had depression
this is going to be the next big
challenge for government and they've got
to start preparing for it
you mentioned there your own experiences
doing sort of lockdown during the
pandemic
um what would your advice be to people
watching the show maybe who
feel that they are struggling is there
any things that people can do just to
try
and make themselves feel better to try
and pull themselves out is there any
advice that you can
give people well it is hard and it's
very hard to sort of give general advice
to people who will be having their own
very very personal
struggles but i do think that talking is
the single most important thing that you
can do
i actually think that you know in in the
book my partner fiona has written a
chapter about what it's like
living with me when i'm depressed and it
was actually interesting for me to read
that
to get her sense we've obviously talked
about it for 40 years
but actually sometimes when you write
things down you get a better sense
and what's interesting from her
perspective was that she felt there was
nothing she could do
and yet for me as the person who was
going through the depressions
you know pretty much every stage of the
40 years we've been together
actually her just being there for me to
talk to when i felt like talking was
incredibly important
so the most important thing to me is
actually to
not to feel ashamed never to feel that
it's anybody's fault
it just is depression anxiety these
conditions
just are but i often feel now the fact
that whereas i used to be in denial
about it i used to not talk about it
now that i'm very open about it the
first thing i do when i feel it coming
on is say to fiona
it's happening again we both worked out
ways to deal with that better so i'd say
talking is the single most important
thing that we can do
whether with a family member a friend a
colleague or
it may be with a medical professional
but just talk
is the best way out of it thank you it's
really good advice there and obviously
very important for people
like yourself with a public profile
people have been very successful in
their lives
to talk about your own experiences so we
really thank you for coming the program
to doing that thank you